Problems are very important to every organisation.
Those things that you have on your wall,
a lot of people have professionalism,
integrity and all of that but
until those things make sense, you know
in the runnings and the pressures of your business
then they are just words.
Corvallis ships culture because it um,
defines the behaviours of people in an organisation
and um, I think that for the longest time
people in branding,
you know brand strategy,
um, they pay a little attention to brand,
um, to Corvallis
but not too much. Um,
I think that the development of your core values in
like dream branding,
um, in the, you know
design of your brand strategy should be also in like,
you should flow into your,
you know hitch house strategy in terms of recruitment
because when you hire people based on your covens
you tend to have a group of people that are
um, you know
similar, you know
they are connected by a set of values
and that will initiate,
you know a similar behaviours which will eventually
form what we called culture of the organisation
and culture largely
determines if or not you'll be able to meet
your set goal
if you're able to achieve your vision.
So I think it's something that every leader
should think about
designing and crafting core values,
um, for your organization
and also moving past that
to ensuring that it forms part of your um,
hiring strategy.